[Музика]
Привіт усім і ласкаво просимо на
урок англійської, мене звуть Анна, і сьогодні
ми збираємося розпочати нову тему молодіжний
спосіб життя просто свідок того, що
невідомо про рок і морозиво старенька
Вакаса Істер, її звуть ван
Оппенгеймер бачата  no vote mo youth
lifestyles, тож давайте відразу перейдемо
до способу життя молоді,
підлітки, як і ви, на екрані
ви можете побачити зображення, які насправді
ілюструють спосіб життя різних
підлітків у всьому світі, щоб ви могли
побачити різні субкультури,
тому  тут це перший kpop, і
людей, які є огорожею цієї культури
, називають kpoppers, тому що таке k-pop
k-pop, це поп-музика, яка створюється в
Кореї, зазвичай є гурти kpop, які
складаються лише з дівчат або хлопців  тільки
вони дуже популярні серед корейської
молоді та, звичайно, людей
по всьому світу, а
також другий спосіб життя, другий, який називається
субкультурою, це цілі дівчата, які цілі
дівчата ці актуа  lly – це блогери,
б’юті-блогери або взагалі блогери YouTube,
які купують якісь речі, косметику,
одяг чи щось інше, і
вони розпаковують на камеру, тому ці
люди насправді цілі дівчата –
шопоголіки, які люблять показувати, що у
них є в магазинах  так що наступна
культура - це м'який гранж, тож це більше
стосується одягу, а
не просто способу життя, тому, як ви бачите,
дівчина одягнена в якийсь певний одяг,
і це те, що м'який гранж є на
зображенні лісу, ви можете побачити
ілюстрацію культури сіпанку, ця
культура з'явилася сім  років тому
приблизно в tumblr і, як ви
бачите, він показує досить цікаві
кольори волосся і татуювання на тілах людей,
і насправді ці люди
досить сонячні блискучі та веселі,
так що і останній на цьому слайді
дівчата tumblr ви можете побачити  зображення
дуже мальовничого представника цієї
культури, тому дівчата з tumblr захоплюються
косметикою, вони люблять гарний одяг,
вони люблять бренди та  вони люблять
фотографуватися, і давайте подивимося на ще
три типи ядра культурних норм,
і ви можете побачити Беллу Хадід як
представника цього стилю тут, на
цій картинці, тож це більше про
одяг, а також про
ваш спосіб життя загалом, так що  це
нормальний суд нормкор, як ви можете бачити
на початку слова, є
слово норма, що означає, що всі
нормальні, вони думають, що ні
в кого немає нічого особливого, так само, як ми
всі однакові, і в одязі Белли
Хадід ти  бачу, що так, вона
одягнена в щось дуже просте, а не
особливе
Стів Джобс, до речі, власник корпорації Apple,
він також був дуже
мальовничим значним
представником цієї культури мем-ядра, а що
означає мем-мем насправді є
ілюстрацією концепції, яку всі
знає і мем ядро, це стиль,
який є типом культури, яка
насправді використовує меми, чи
то смішні картинки, чи
то кепські  pts бренди, які всі
знають у своєму одязі в
аксесуарах тощо, тому тут
ви можете побачити, як Кеті Перрі
має гаманець із вивісками McDonald's на
табличці McDonald's, це досить підло, оскільки
всі про це знають, і кожен
може впізнати це на зображенні як
Знак і останній тип культури,
який ми виділили сьогодні, це yucky
so yucky це молода творча особистість,
яка насправді новий хіпстер, тому Які
новий хіпстер, оскільки ви бачите, що чоловік
на малюнку носить модний
одяг і  він, здається, досить
самовпевнений, тому він представник
культури yucky молода творча
особистість добре, тому тепер, коли ми
розглянули найбільш значущих
представників сучасних молодіжних
культур, давайте подивимося і
прочитаємо інтерв’ю з одним із  цілі
дівчата, у яких є блогер, який
розпаковує свої відео, і
журналіст Guardian із Guardian,
це дуже відомий журнал, тож
подивіться на свій скринь  ens молодіжні субкультури,
що вони зараз читають, слухайте та стежте
за текстом. Зверніть увагу на слова,
виділені жирним шрифтом.
Вернон Веласко голосування не зустрічається словацькою мовою в
ритмі відео, тож давайте почнемо
читати по телефону Гелена
пояснює, що таке для мене ціла дівчина
Ви ходите по магазинах
одягу чи косметичних засобів, вона каже, тоді
ви знімаєте відео та показуєте глядачам на
YouTube, що у вас є, ви переглядаєте
предмети одягу один за одним Я думаю,
що люди отримують з них, це не
показує, як багато грошей  Бога
чи чогось іншого, крім способу життя, ви можете побачити,
як живе одна людина, на який смак вона,
якщо ви хочете критикувати молодіжний культ,
який передбачає створення відео про ваші
покупки, тоді Галіна дуже
заінтригує вас, ви зіткнетеся з аргументом, що це
не просто показати, що ви »  я зрозуміла,
вона каже, що за відео також стоїть цілий творчий процес
, і це те, що
мені подобається,
вибираючи правильну музику від
фільму до монтажу, іноді я навіть
розкадровки, тому що я хочу певні
кадри, як я можу представити різні предмети
та подібні речі,
крім того, вона каже, що це справжня
спільнота, на її думку, багато
дівчат вмикають камеру, тому що
це спосіб розмовляти з людьми,
не виходячи на вулицю та  зіткнутися з їхніми страхами. Я
знаю, що так було зі мною.
Я відмовився від фотоапарата, тому що я був
вдома, хворий і справді
нудьгований, і це допомогло моїй впевненості
в тому, що є ця спільнота, де
можна поговорити з однодумцями, тому
тепер, коли ми прочитали текст, ви стежите
за мною, і ви точно
помітили слова, які
виділені жирним шрифтом, тепер наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
зіставити ці слова з визначеннями,
подивіться, і ви побачите наступне зображення в
лівій колонці  визначення
в правому стовпці ви можете побачити 11 слів,
які нам потрібно знайти у відповідності з ними, тому давайте
спочатку поглянемо на слова, щоб
це слова з тексту, я
прочитаю їх уголос, ви можете повторити  t після мене
один культ до пункту 3 впевненість для
субкультури 5 спосіб життя 6 до показу 7
розкадровка 8 справжня 9 спільнота 10
однодумці 11 зіткнутися зі страхом, тому тепер, коли
ми переглянули слова з тексту,
давайте подивимося на перше
визначення таким чином типовий спосіб
життя окремої групи чи культури, то
що було б слово зі
стовпця праворуч, яке ми могли б використати для відповідності
до цього визначення ah cassava Zuko
нездатний
the Vltava shop ziad не виконується в
бізнес-переліку  кінчик
квадратури PO vegeta має керувати Ропером
ковдру з бантиком для цього визначення ми
обов'язково будемо використовувати п'яте слово, яке
є спосіб життя, спосіб життя, друге
визначення соціальної групи зі специфічною
поведінкою, яка відрізняє її від
інших dr.  Сезана Якіма також
вразила Клода поведілья які цією ніччю, тому
особливе не схвалюю це переконайтеся, давайте
подумаємо, що це може бути,
це слово має відношення до нашої теми, тож це
підкультура номер чотири, ми говоримо
про культуру в цілому, ми говоримо
про групу  з людей, які поділяють цю
культуру всередині загальної культури
, є крихітні субкультури ogia
zahana cultura a yeah field cultura
типова для загрібання субкультури епізоду
ama давайте перейдемо до наступної
окремої речі, щоб це було
об'єктом і це було б  слово елемент,
який нам потрібно зіставити з цим визначенням,
наступний — панель, на якій розміщено набір
ескізів, тому зазвичай це
дерев’яна панель, і ви можете використовувати
малюнки та деякі фотографії, які ви
хотіли б проілюструвати свої мрії, використовуючи всі
ці речі, тому ми використовували б слово
розкадровка для такої речі, тому панель
із зображеннями з набором ескізів
, які розташовані на ній, називається
розкадровкою, ви, можливо, чули це
слово  mood board
suta slovo mood board - тип
taquoia Pinelli з рекламною передпоїздкою
lat curtain capability mr.  vataj
неприємний захист розкадровки двоюрідний брат
і розповідь про нас через поцілунок прямо номер на
дошці настрою затишний противний, тож давайте
перейдемо до наступного визначення, щоб похвалитися
чимось, щоб з гордістю показати, щоб
якості Джуми завдяки цьому показували
чудовий тон, який міг би бути фразою,
яка буде  відповідність цьому визначенню,
звичайно, показує наступну
якість або стан впевненості, коли
ви впевнені, що робите, коли
ви впевнені, що ви приємна
людина, і ви можете це зробити, тоді ви можете
зателефонувати  ти впевнений або коли ми
говоримо про державу, звичайно,
впевненість або просто постійно впевнений
Томас Данн, фемініст, словацька впевненість,
наступне визначення – це G і група,
присвячена спільній ідеї, тому, коли ми
говоримо про групу людей, які
поділяють те саме  З тієї ж точки
зору ми б назвали таку групу
людей культом наступним щирим і
чесним Джеррі, це тільки я, яке може
бути словом, яке ми можемо використовувати як синонім
до цих двох  давайте подумаємо, і, звичайно
, це справжнє, тож давайте перейдемо до наступного
визначення I група людей зі
спільними інтересами, як ми називаємо
людей, які поділяють однакові інтереси, і
вони можуть мати певні точки зору
, які однакові, і яким словом ми б ми
використовуйте тут, що було б спільнотою номер дев'ять,
тож українською мовою ми могли б
використовувати переклад spin nota Turkish spill
no obeah daniela de aqui злиття odd na
kabhi spin ви знаєте, що застрягли в тероризмі,
тому спільнота спільних інтересів тепер
наступна у мене схожі смаки чи
думки  як ми можемо назвати цей процес
того, що це холодно, давайте подивимося,
і так, звичайно, це номер 10
, схожий на мене, що означає, що вона
має схожі смаки чи думки з
іншою людиною, твоїм другом або, можливо,
людиною, яка не є  ваш друг
і останнє визначення, давайте подивимося на
нього, щоб боротися з тим, чого ви боїтеся,
тож яка фраза може відповідати
цьому визначенню,
безсумнівно, це номер 11  зіткнутися зі страхом, що
Паваротті може бути сильним, це
словосполучення, яке нам потрібно використовувати, коли ми говоримо,
що ми боремося з тим, чого ми є, ми
боїмося добре, а тепер давайте подивимося
на наступну картинку, на якій насправді
потрібно перевірити розуміння  текст,
тож давайте подивимося на запитання,
перевірте ваше розуміння питання 1, що
таке ціле відео, чи пам’ятаєте ви, що це
таке з тексту, дайте йому щось скажімо,
скажімо, 15 секунд, звичайно, ціле відео
– це відео, де блогер робить
розпаковування того, що вони купили, це
може бути одяг, це можуть бути косметичні
засоби, як-от косметика чи щось
подібне, наступне питання, чому
люди знімають цілі відео, як ви
думаєте, які причини можуть бути для
себе, не забудьте зробити це англійською
і, звичайно, пам'ятайте, що було
згадано в тексті про це, чому
люди знімають цілі відео, у них є
різні причини, вони хочуть поділитися
тим, що у них є, вони хочуть
це показати, але зазвичай не
показують  ff правильно, тому вони не публікують це,
вони просто діляться своїми ідеями своїми
думками номер 3 як Галина
описує спільноту, чи пам'ятаєте ви
слово, яким вона це описувала,
насправді вона казала, що
спільнота досить щира, чесна
підтримує це слово  вона використовувала
взагалі була справжня так справжня спільнота
ось як Галина описує цю
спільноту цілих відеомейкерів
номер 4 це тепер ви самі подумайте
що ви думаєте про цю
проблему цього питання на вашу думку
як можна зробити дірку  відео допомагає
підвищити їхню впевненість, як ви
думаєте, тому що я думаю, що коли ви знімаєте
відео на камеру, коли показуєте те, що
маєте, коли показуєте те, що ви
купили, це насправді допомагає вам зрозуміти,
що ви гарний оратор і  у вас є
так багато речей, якими ви можете поділитися з людьми, так
багато ідей, і це насправді підвищує вашу
впевненість до гарного рівня, коли ви
працюєте з камерою, а коли ви
практикуєте і практикуєте це номер п'ять  e
які переваги спілкування з
однодумцями і які можуть бути
недоліки, це знову
питання до вас, щоб подумати особисто, що
ви думаєте, що добре в спілкуванні
з однодумцями, що погано в
цьому, звичайно, коли ми  розмовляти з однодумцями,
коли ми є частиною спільноти,
ми можемо поділитися своїми ідеями, ми можемо говорити
про них, і ми можемо вчитися на цьому,
але недоліком може бути те, що ви
можете стати вузькими, тому не
забувайте, що ви  Ви є частиною спільноти
, не забувайте звертати увагу на інші
речі, які відбуваються в усьому
світі та навколо вас, тому тепер, коли ми
закінчили із запитаннями, давайте перейдемо
до перегляду словника та практики,
тож тепер на цьому світлі  ви можете побачити
фотографії найвідоміших способів
життя молодих людей і підлітків,
найвідоміших субкультур і насправді
праворуч у нас є спіраль, де слова,
які ми щойно використали в нашому тексті, щоб
ви могли витягти слова з цієї
спіралі, нехай  подивіться на це, тож тут у
нас є кілька слів і фраз, які
нам потрібно розшифрувати, тож давайте
подивимося, що зараз спіраль починається з
фрази обличчя страх давайте запишемо це
обличчя страх ви пам’ятаєте, що це  чи
це означає боротися з чимось, чого ви боїтеся,
давайте подивимося на наступне
слово його com2 та ity, і це
слово спільнота, це правильно, давайте запишемо
його спільнота розлив, але
добре, яке може бути наступне слово, яке
починається з G і  він закінчується на E чи можете ви
вгадати, що це
таке  це наступне слово, яке ми
маємо тут, добре
після розкадрування, воно починається з одного
слова, потім дефіс, а потім інша
частина слова, і це однодумці
, не забувайте - це так однодумці чи
ні?  Не кажи, що лудус розлив, мій дядько
каже лава Ма  ya diffie, так це слово
має - добре, що йде після однодумців,
воно починається з нас, закінчується на E, і це
показує частину культури, звичайно
, це слово субкультура, давайте запишемо
його,
субкультура, добре, а що йде після
слова субкультура  ми бачимо, що воно починається
на C, воно також закінчується на E, і
це слово означає бути впевненим у
тому, що ви робите. Слово це впевненість
гарна робота давайте запишемо слово
впевненість, так впевненість, і що ми маємо
після впевненості, добре, що  це
слово, яке починається на L, закінчується на E,
і воно розповідає нам про спосіб
життя людини, що могло б бути словом
подивіться так, впевнений, що це слово lifestyle
добре, ми майже закінчили, так що
щодо способу життя, що таке  після
стилю життя з у нас є слово, яке є
досить коротким, в ньому всього чотири
літери, і це слово культ,
воно досить просте побачити, el-tee,
молодець, наступне слово, яке ми бачимо
, також є коротким  є також jus  t
чотири літери в ньому, і це слово використовується
для розмови про об'єкти, коли є
лише окремий об'єкт, слово є предметом,
а останнє слово насправді є фразою,
фразовим дієсловом, який показує нам, що ми
чимось хвалимося або
щось показуємо  з гордістю, так що це похизуватися
добре, так що тепер ми закінчили з
гіршим, ми розшифрували спіраль і
давайте потренуємося використовувати ці слова в
реченнях, тож давайте подивимося на
наступний слайд, ми повинні використовувати ці слова
в реченнях, їх чотири  додаткові слова,
тому нам знадобиться лише сім слів,
які будуть використані в реченнях, давайте
ще раз подивимося на слова,
це слова, з якими ми щойно працювали
по спіралі, тому зіткніться зі справжньою спільнотою страху,
подібним до дошки розповідей
субкультура впевненість, спосіб життя культовий
предмет, демонстрація, тож давайте подивимося
на перше речення, нам потрібно буде
з'ясувати з його контексту, яке слово,
яке слово насправді нам потрібно буде використати
тут, тому номер один я був дуже здивований  d
коли Джейн підтримала мене в тій ситуації,
я ніколи не думав, що вона може бути такою, давайте
думати про Джейн як про щиру людину, правда,
ми не очікували, що вона буде настільки підтримкою,
ми не очікували, що вона буде настільки чесною
і сказати, що ми повинні  використовувати тут
справжня. Я ніколи не думав, що вона може бути настільки
справжньою, номер два. Дуже
важливо підтримувати себе у формі та вести здоровий образ
сьогодні, тож що людина може бути
здоровою, якщо людина підтримує форму, якщо людина здорова,
то це
буде  спосіб життя цієї людини, і якщо
ми говоримо про спосіб життя,
то це, безумовно, слово спосіб життя
здоровий спосіб життя сьогодні дуже важливий
номер три,
вистрибнувши з літака Джон зрозумів, що
це був момент, коли він нарешті
злякався, що він зробив  покінчи зі страхом, який він
нарешті зумів протистояти цьому, тому, коли ми
говоримо про це, коли ми використовуємо
слово обличчя в цьому реченні, не забувайте,
що ми говоримо про минулі
дії, є шоу
Bhuvana Ямараджа Мухаррама
Опра  ти м  iss Veneto vahana gee Слава
зрозумів, що навіть не встигнути
нижню частину обличчя Майя б Рамона
ти знаєш,
Честер V формат місяць спричиняв
вологу він нарешті зіткнувся зі своїм страхом
номер чотири у моєму гардеробі так багато одягу, що
я знаю, що я повинен позбутися
деяких  але це так важко, що ти думаєш,
я чув, що Раджа Бахадур ланцюг
багато, але не дати, якщо ви понюхаєте
пост буддійська операція дна Конохи,
коли ми говоримо про окремі
речі, нам, звичайно, потрібно використовувати слово елемент,
але тут ми маємо  множина ми
говоримо про багато речей, тому ми будемо
використовувати словосполучення, це форма множини
номер п'ять. Ви можете уявити, що Кейт прийшла в
школу вчора і почала зі своїм
новим iPhone, вона бурмоче, ми з
Кейт, замовкни, ти, шлюха,
учениця, заткнись  з цим wim знаю, де
мій телефон я не в партнер заведений
салон в пілатес йога zlobin нижня частина
Shibata ik еквівалент повільно рівності
англійською, що було б фразовим дієсловом,
тож дієсловом і  прийменник
так, звичайно, з’являється, тому вона
почала демонструвати своїм новим
iPhone наступне речення, коли мріє про
щось, що ви повинні візуалізувати це в ефірі,
яку річ, яку панель із
зображеннями ви використовуватимете, щоб уявити свої
мрії чи свої цілі, які ви хочете  щоб
досягти настільки чітко, що це була б
розкадровка номер сім, останнє
тут, здавалося, вона завжди знала, чого
хоче, і ніколи не втрачала її те, що вона
завжди була впевнена в тому, чого хоче, тому вона
була впевнена, але тут вона ніколи не
втрачала впевненості, не  Не забувайте, що це
іменник, який нам потрібно використовувати тут у формі зараз,
щоб вона, здавалося, завжди знала, чого
хоче, і ніколи не втрачала впевненості
ванасса це знання ohoven ocotilla
in e : f3 chala
була ти феміністкою добре, це все наразі
і зараз  давайте перевіримо, чи можете ви
здогадатися, що означають ці слова на дошці.
Вау, що це,
ви можете зрозуміти, що це таке
нерухомість пензлик
стенограми сонний пан.  свідок одного способу
з дітьми / Revere hommage she was
most of her data shot slava made against
a huge problem to let's
going and let's look at the
first soh, давайте поглянемо на спільноту
ага, це слово спільнота, чи можете ви
згадати, як  ми запишемо це, як ми пишемо це,
щоб це було C Ох, ви і IT, чому
спільнота розповсюджує нота номер 2
субкультуру, щоб субкультура субкультура
ах давайте запишемо це субкультура
добре зроблено, а що щодо впевненості номер 3 впевненість
це феміністка давайте напишемо  це
слово також починається на С до речі, а
не так, як ви можете побачити в
транскрипції, тому звук впевненості міг би
буква С на початку номер 4 культ
культ в українському культі давайте запишемо
це також починається на букву С
побачимось  el-tee культ номер 5
предмет однини простий предмет
окремий, тож давайте запишемо
слово предмет i тем номер 6
однодумець однодумець ми використовуємо це слово, щоб говорити
про думки людей Сімі  lar
думки,
тож давайте запишемо це слово як розум
, зверніть увагу на те, як ми пишемо це
слово,
між двома словами не вистачає однієї речі, що ви
пам’ятаєте, що це – правильно, нам потрібно
поставити дефіс між схожими та однодумцями
моя мама  міг подумати про гонорари,
це майже подобається, однодумець номер
сім, так що це здається
важкою правдою, але це не справжня
справжня пряма щира справжня
це слово справжній і останній тут
спосіб життя спосіб життя дух робота
життя давайте запишемо це одне
слово, немає - немає простору
між двома словами життя і стиль, тому стиль
життя це спосіб життя
добре, так це зі словами, і
це все з практикою для нашого
сьогоднішнього дня  урок дуже дякую
за увагу,
vonabell upon you Anna & Lisa como de
viata class for bituminous tokoha rasa
побачимося наступного разу
[музика]